[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEWART MILES:
I'm Stewart Miles.
I'm a software engineer on
Firebase and Fun Propulsion
Labs.
[INAUDIBLE] I'm here to talk
to you about Firebase today.
Firebase is a suite
of services to help
you build unique experiences
and grow successful businesses.
So we're part of all of the
different stages of development
when you're building your game.
It helps you develop, grow,
and earn more from your games.
And many of the features are
provided at absolutely no cost.
I'll provide an overview of
a subset of the features.
So after working with
our development community
for the past few months, I'm
proud to announce today the 3.0
release of our mobile SDKs for
C++ and Unity developers that
target iOS and Android.
So you'll be able
to access Firebase
from your favorite game engine.
And Firebase supports
iOS, Android, and the web,
and we have admin
SDKs for your service.
If you're selling
a premium game,
it's valuable to
measure user engagement
to understand whether players
will return or purchase
your next release.
This is especially important
in freemium games, where
you might want to measure
engagement to make sure
that users are converting on
your ads as much as possible,
while perhaps purchasing
in-app content.
Firebase analytics allows you
to measure umlimited player
behavior at no cost.
Firebase analytics provides
a pre-built dashboard
for common data
analysis scenarios,
and implicitly captures
events like the first time
your game is opened by user,
engagement time, retention,
in-app purchases
where it's possible,
and user demographics as
well, with minimum effort.
And also you can log
your own custom events
on top of all of that.
In addition, our
dashboard allows
you to find your own audiences,
cohorts, and funnels,
and user properties.
If our dashboard isn't
sufficient for your needs,
you can pool data
using Google Cloud's
BigQuery or into your
own analysis tools.
Or you could even use Google's
data studio for data analysis
as well.
So try it out now.
It's really, really easy.
This is all the code that you
need if you're a c++ developer.
There is some build
stuff if you're C++,
but this is all you could need
to get going with analytics.
And this gives you all the
built-in event tracking.
In Unity, you just
import a plug-in,
you write a couple
of lines of code--
this is the key one here--
and you're off and running.
That's it.
We also have Firebase
remote config.
It's an experiment
framework which
enables you to adjust
game parameters in order
to maximize user engagement.
So you can deploy
your game, and you
can adjust parameters without
redeploying a new build.
For example, if you suspect
players are leaving your game
due to your ad
display strategy, you
can run an experiment where
you reduce the frequency of ad
display or move your ad display
points to see whether it
affects user retention.
Or perhaps people just prefer
blue cats in their games.
You can also use remote config
to change any parameters
in your game, like
UI, ad placement,
difficulty, or whatever
you can imagine.
We provide a web interface
for remote configuration
so non-programming
members of your team
can configure and
run an experiments.
So, game designers, operations
teams, things like that.
In addition, Firebase provides
push notification support.
So we have Cloud messaging
notifications that
enable you to reengage players.
So this is trying to bring
them back into your game.
For example, if you've just
added new content to your game,
you could send a
push notification
to users who have completed--
I don't know-- a good
chunk of the game
to tell them to come back
and try out the new content.
We also provide a web UI
for push notifications,
again allowing
non-engineering team members
to send notifications
to players of the game.
After notifications
have been sent,
we also have a
dashboard that enables
you to measure their impact.
So we have a funnel report,
and all of the analytics
get bubbled up into
Firebase analytics
as well, which can
pull out into BigQuery.
To grow your audience
or reengage players,
we provide dynamic
links and app invites.
For example, a player
could share a game
where you feed sushi to animals,
they click the Invite button,
they select who to share with,
they will receive an email link
to the game, and then when
they click on the link,
it will install the
game and potentially
provide them with a reward.
You can decide what to do
with the link yourself.
In addition, the
player who shared
can also be rewarded something
for sharing the game.
We have an
authentication API that
allows you to authenticate with
multiple identity providers.
Users can sign
anonymously, and then later
upgrade to an identity provider.
Like out of the box, like
one of these, or they
can use an anonymous account.
We also have a
real-time database,
which allows you to
store game state,
like available
characters, maps, etc.
Set updates are synchronized
in hundreds of milliseconds,
so you could build
turn-based games, or just
store data for
your game in there.
You could also do something like
building collaborative editing
of maps in a marble rolling
game, like one of our demos,
or you could build
leaderboards with the database.
Finally, Firebase
storage allows you
to store large chunks of data.
This distributed
quickly for CDN.
It also allows you to set
content protection rules,
so that you could do things
like offer premium content.
If you want to find
out more, we've
got a session on
Firebase at 12:45
on Thursday, AdMob at
3 o'clock on Thursday,
and you can also download demos.
Also check out
firebase.google.com
for more information.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]